back everybody the newest member of the
squad is calling for the abolition of
capitalism
get rid of it he hasn't been sworn in
yet congressman-elect jamal bowman
demanding a transformation
of the american economy saying quote i
believe our current system of capitalism
is slavery by another name we've moved
from physical chattel
enslavement and physical racial
segregation
to a plantation economic system it's a
system that's not working so we need a
new system says the congressman elect
you know tyrus i think that comparing
anything anything to slavery
or to the holocaust is lazy
intellectually lazy
and totally inappropriate let's say you
yeah because the only other word for
slavery is
uh slavery uh that is a complete
ridiculousness to even try to put it
equate it any other way
uh this country capitalism is based on
what
individual achievement you pull your
bootstraps up as i used to say back in
the day
you get you get on the grind you educate
yourself you do what you do you work you
work you work you sacrifice
and the american dream works for
everybody there's opportunity everywhere
every job in this country whether it's
the president
or it is a janitor any person can hold
it we know that to be true
so to say that there is no opportunity
anyone is ridiculous
can a whole group be taken up and rised
up in capitalism
no individual achievement you can set up
things in your community you can give
back
you can help others you can always
strengthen education you can always
work on things here and there but this
is the best system in the universe
and i am living proof of that and no way
in slave reform as anyone
ever made me do anything with slavery
and if you don't know what slavery is
that we still have some great great
grandparents around
that can inform you and let you know
that this ain't nothing like slavery
bruh
not even close not even a little nothing
ain't nothing like it
ain't nothing like that i totally agree
me too standardized testing though what
about that dana it's tough on
kids from the inner city we know that
kids who go to bad schools but how else
do you
weed out the best students this guy
wants to abolish
standardized testing what do you say
well i also wonder though if he wants to
abandon that does he want to
have more school choice i mean because
that's an option right you could figure
out a way to have more alternatives to
education
which could help and i think one of the
things that's the key to america's
success is the
is economic mobility like do you have
the opportunity to move up
and the system is not perfect um of
course there are things
that you might want to change here and
there and especially as technology
increases
so should we make sure that for example
rural broadband
is available to people who don't live in
big cities that get all the attention
there are things you could do around the
edges but there's a reason so many
people
are trying to get into the united states
of america because there is opportunity
here sure
it is the best system that we have it's
not perfect but it is the best one we
have
you know my problem jesse with socialism
is that all these socialists have great
ideas about spending other people's
money but they have no idea how to make
money
what do you think it's a good point
um first i'd like to congratulate the
congressman for
breaking the gender barrier of the squad
i i had no idea the squad was accepting
new members
is there an initiation ritual i mean did
they have to bring
rubble from a toppled statue to aoc
i'm curious about about if he got tapped
and how
but i looked into this guy's background
it's an amazing background he grew up
dirt poor got himself into college
played college football
then went and got a master's degree and
then got a doctorate in education so now
i guess we have to call him
dr bowman and then he founded his own
school
and then he became a congressman and now
he's accepting checks from capitalists
so he could stay a congressman
i mean capitalism allowed him to succeed
and tyrus put it perfectly that all
those students
in the school that dr bowman founded
are eventually one day going to be
invested in
by people who see their talent or see
their hard work or see their ideas
and that's going to raise their standard
of living so this again is the
opposite of slavery and that's a
beautiful thing
i i just i'm so irked by his invocation
of that uh
that horror that historic horror all
right but you know katie
socialism defunding the police joe biden
even admitted it
these were disastrous issues for
democrats
you know god bless bowman and as jesse
says he's an amazing american success
story but all across the board elsewhere
the democrats got wiped out
on the defund the police and socialism
as as issues katie
yeah and the irony geraldo is that he is
arguing that capitalism is the enemy
here but if you look over the past nine
months
you've actually seen an economic system
in the united states that is closer to
socialism and communism than capitalism
because the government is now in charge
of telling people when they can go to
work
how much you know how many people can be
in their business how many
you know when they can operate their
businesses who can be in business big
box stores are enabled by
state and local governments to be open
while small businesses are completely
crushed you have
special interest groups like hollywood
production companies that have an in
with the local authorities who get to
operate right in the parking lot of a
small business owner who has a
restaurant
outside that she spent money on but
she's not allowed to operate
i mean that that's the type of system
that he wants is what we are seeing
right now and it has been horrible for
everybody and
big government is enabled by big
business
which is the big corporations that he's
complaining about so if you want to look
at what's going on and where we're going
the last nine months are pretty good
example of the system that he wants
not a free market capitalist system
for the record we have had a republican
president uh you know so i think there's
plenty of blame to go around
he's against the lockdowns who's against
more lockdown toronto
well uh not against trump
i i i think that there's we as we were
in a panic we had we're trying to do the
best we can
you know governors mayors they're just
they're not perfect but
it is what it is why